hey youtubers huge news HBO just
confirmed that we might not get new Game
of Thrones after season 7 until 2019 so
I'll explain what's going on they also
talked about the prequels it sounds like
the worst thing ever just based on the
pitch but what they're saying is is that
Dan and Dave haven't started writing
season 8 yet and they want to give them
as much time as possible so there's a
good-news bad-news aspect to this I'll
explain the bad news first rip the
band-aid off but there is a new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video if for an HBO now
subscription but what's going on is
they're saying it could be a year and a
half after season 7 before we get season
8 depending on how long it takes them to
write the scripts write like a solid
final season because there are six
episodes in reading between the lines it
sounds like they don't want to wind up
with a lost situation if you never
watched it was this great series with
this crazy mythology that fell apart
towards the end it has it's really
dissatisfying finale so they don't want
to run into a situation where you have
something as big as Game of Thrones that
just Peters out in the last season like
oh you know it used to be good but it
went out with a whimper whereas the
season 7 delay was mostly just weather
based they just needed to wait for
actual winter to come in real life to
the locations where they film most of
the things south of the wall so HBO just
low-key preparing you for 2019 Game of
Thrones should that come to pass the
other option is if they get things
started a little bit faster and it just
comes out a little bit later in 2018
they're calling season 8 more cinematic
than it's been in previous seasons if
you didn't think that it looked like a
really awesome movie made as a TV show
before season 8 is going to top that in
a big way so you'll see less scenes of
them sitting around just talking to each
other in more big battle of the bastards
level action so just be prepared for
Game of Thrones in 2019 but the good
news the actual good news about this is
that it gives them more time to figure
out what the next prequel series is
going to be right after they made the
announcement about the four series that
they're developing Martin came out and
said no there's actually five I'm
involved with all of them but none of
them are going to be a sequel series
they're not traditional spin-offs
they're all going to be prequels one of
them is potentially in anthology series
so it'd be like a limited run they would
jump around as they
to American Horror Story style but the
others are more traditional series just
set during different times in a
different location he confirmed that
they will not be doing Robert's
rebellion and they will not be doing the
Duncan egg series because he said he
didn't want to repeat what happened with
the main series where the series gets
past the books and he still has plans to
continue the Duncan egg series
so right now top of the list is dance of
the Dragons Blackfyre rebellion war the
ninepenny kings series that are set in
Essos you know places that we've never
seen before
all those things are on the table you
guys can let me know what you want them
to do I feel like Blackfyre rebellion or
dance the dragons would probably the
most solid bet you could do familiar
things but they'd also feel unique from
the main series and they wouldn't
feature the same characters a couple of
other really solid pigs with used to be
Aegon's conquest or the rise of the
Valyrian freehold or you can even do the
doom of Valyria or even something in a
shy that's the place where Melisandre
came from where you train to be a shadow
binder and it's also weird to nurses
dragon eggs for purchase there's a rumor
that there are caves which dragons used
to roost in all along this coastline
over here so no matter what time period
you set it in there are ways to work
dragons into the series so it's not all
bad news and it increases the likelihood
exponentially that the final season
won't suck and that we'll get a spin-off
series that'll start very soon after the
main series stops they did say they
didn't want to roll out the next series
right after season 8 ends like they'll
be a bit of a breathing period to give
it the proper send-off is the way they
put it when is the final episode airs
late 2018 early 2019 we'll probably see
the first episode from the prequel err
late 2019 but let me know what do you
guys think about all this I know it's a
bummer to hear that we might get a full
year without Game of Thrones but
remember the books are still being
published Martin will finish winds of
winter sometime in that area if he
doesn't finish it this year and there's
no Game of Thrones next year I would bet
that he finishes it next year in that
would give him more time to collaborate
on those season 8 scripts because he
hasn't really been involved in
production - season 7 just because it's
taking him away from winds of winter so
much so what's going to happen is as I
was originally planning on making a
Tyrian video next before this news drop
so I'll post that on Sunday but leave
all
your request for Game of Thrones bonus
videos in the comment congratulations to
the new giveaway winner Matthew Cosette
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video I'll just announce the winner
when I post that next Game of Thrones
video while you wait for that you can
click here to learn all about ice
dragons and you can click here to learn
all about the Cersei Map theory from
season 7 thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight